it could soon look like this in many
more parts of the world global warming
poses a threat to us all but especially
to those who live in poverty-stricken
countries the number of people who have
to fight to survive is climbing
worldwide does climate change pose a
security risk around 800 million people
currently have no access to clean
drinking water and there's less and less
of it to go around more than 900 million
people are malnourished climate change
is turning more and more regions into a
wasteland hostile to life once fertile
soil is growing barren
and many areas have already become so
dry that little grows their food crops
will soon be an even shorter supply to
escape the threats of thirst and
starvation people will seek to escape
the regions and countries affected
the struggle for resources will grow
more acute and the number of conflicts
will rise
climate change will also cause sea
levels to rise storms and flooding will
strike islands and coastal areas large
stretches of land could disappear
beneath the waters and the changes will
also affect cities and industrial
centers weakening economies all over the
world climate change poses a threat to
everyone on the planet but it's
explosive potential is most dangerous
and countries that are politically
unstable or at war they could quickly be
confronted with insurmountable problems
we can only stop climate change together
you